we're going to begin today with actress
issa rae she also falls in the badass
category she first became widely known
to tv audiences and her hit show was
called and still is called insecure she
is not only the show's star but it's
creator it's writer and executive
producer that's a tyler perry move right
there now five years later issa rae is
considered a hollywood powerhouse she
signed a multi-multi multi-million
dollar film and tv deal giving warner
media her content exclusively for the
next five years insecure's fifth and
final season premieres on sunday night
so we met up with issa ray at the bowery
hotel where all the cool people go in
new york city to reflect on this moment
okay so here we are in season five i
don't know whether to cry or to cheer
cheer cheer for us for five years fans
have cheered for issa rey's character
issa dee as she navigates her career i'm
quitting
friendships forever 21 earrings they
last forever trash and love in her hit
hbo series insecure you ate here already
a couple times the thing that i like so
much about the show and i don't even
know if you're aware of this it's the
expressions that you make
and you know what i mean it could be a
movement it could be a grimace that you
do the device where she's talking in the
mirror oh yeah
who's stressed not you who the best it's
you who gonna kill it i'm sorry i can't
not today wait wait i thought you were
supposed to be hyping me up do you
actually really do that i don't talk in
the mirror to myself but i do
have moments with myself in the mirror
and in the bathroom in particular the
bathroom is like you know the place
where all my best ideas come from the
place where i kind of feel at peace and
i just get to kind of reset and collect
myself insecure has proven to be one of
ray's best ideas the show's first four
seasons racked up 11 emmy nominations
including best comedy series
can you believe how your life has
changed over the last five years
tell me from your perspective what it
feels like for you i feel more
confident that i belong here you know i
feel here in hollywood you mean in
hollywood um
as a storyteller there's a sense of like
i know what i'm doing
yeah because let me remind you about the
last five years for you that and this
gives me so much joy covers of variety
rolling stone
vanity fair
self magazine
you've also produced and starred in at
least three movies and oh by the way you
got married too
i feel like i'm just getting started
it's nice to hear you run that down uh
but i still feel like a beginner in many
ways i have so much more to do listen
you've already inked a ginormous deal
with warner media what does that mean to
you what does this deal mean to you that
deal in particular
i think for me it just means like i have
an opportunity
to bet on myself and someone is betting
on me ray also bet on and secures cast
and crew look at the lives you've
changed your showrunner your executive
producer you yvonne orgy so many people
this was their first of doing anything
like this on this level do you marvel at
that
we changed each other's lives you know
and so in that way i'm just appreciative
to have grown with them and to be in the
trenches with them and we have so many
memories we all had the mission
to open the door and to keep the door
open to make sure that we created a
pipeline i like what you just said to
open the door and keep the door open
because after the first season you
really didn't know what was going to
happen to you
but at least the people who worked on
our show would have experience which is
like
the excuse that hollywood always gives
for why they don't hire people of color
and black people specifically is just ah
have they worked on anything have they
been in a writer's room and you know at
least they could say we worked on one
season of hbo show and
possibly get another job but we were
fortunate enough to get five seasons and
watch people grow i love that you went
that you had a screening party for your
fans and we went to one of those and one
of the people who watches the show said
she wanted to thank you because you're
one of the first people who created the
show
had like the majority and all of the
cast be black and you didn't care what
they thought so thank you because you
showed me i could do it too what is
setting an example to other creatives
mean to you
i mean it means everything because i
know what it meant
for me to watch those shows from the 90s
and aspire to that and think like oh
this is possible for me to do and these
are stories that
people care about these are stories that
matter and shape me and so to be able to
do that for another generation
i'm extremely proud of that we first sat
down with issa rae right before insecure
premiered in october
2016. at the time she was best known for
a very successful web series the
misadventures of awkward black girl it's
interesting that it's called awkward
black girl because i sit here looking at
you and i think ain't nothing awkward
about you issa rae it's you you don't i
you can say you don't know me gail
you don't have my life
no but it is it's it's just within me
like it will never go anywhere
like i've always related to just feeling
uncomfortable and out of place do you
still feel that way yes how can you feel
that way after all the things that
you've accomplished and all that you
said you know i feel comfortable i feel
i'm just getting started but there's
still a part of you that feels that too
i wish i could explain i think that's
something for my therapist to unpack
honestly i guess you didn't hear me the
first time you starred in three movies
you've been on the cover of vanity fair
rolling stone
you've just signed a big deal with
warner and you said there's still a part
of you that feels talk to me in five
years again and if i feel this way shoot
me
honestly
please do
no i don't want to shoot you issa rae
but i do want to talk to you in five
years because
i believe her when she says she's only
getting started when she first came to
hbo with that show she told them ahead
of time i only want it to be five
seasons she didn't know if i was going
to go through the first season the
second she said but i wanted to be five
because it's like going to high school
going to college we're used to four
years and then maybe a year after she's
very happy that it's ending right now
and she's very happy with how it's
ending but she's nervous about how the
fans are going to receive it but she
feels good about what she's done no
doubt i have to say thank you to the
show for putting together stories like
this yesterday we had the ceo of spanx a
woman who started from humble beginnings
yeah and sold off part of her company
for a billion dollars plus um and i can
go home and tell my daughter about her
today i get to say gail sit down with
isa ray again a woman that looks like
you that talks like you on walks like
you and she started online making film
about something that she identifies with
and now she is one of the biggest movers
and shakers in her industry yeah she's
definitely a mogul she goes i don't know
if i i sort of feel like a mogan sort of
feel like i don't but she still says she
has more to do and i like that so we're
cheering her on it the big debut is uh
the finale the final season of insecure
is sunday night on hbo yeah very good
highly recommend